well I mean I think a low-calorie diet
is probably a good thing I think in
humans we don't know there's no data on
what a low-calorie diet does in terms of
diseases and longevity as I said before
by analogy to rodents you would think it
would be a good thing on the other hand
if it made you really miserable to eat a
thousand calories a day and people who
are on that diet tend to be cold they
tend to have very low sex drive they
tend to in some cases be irritable and
so if you're not happy then that gets
back to what we're saying earlier you
may be undoing some of the good that
that diet would otherwise produce so my
feeling is to live sensibly I'm there
the work would advise that I think is
good it's hard to follow but I think
what everybody should do if everybody
could do this it's the best you can do
right now is decide what is your perfect
weight your body weight what's perfect
for you and I think what most people do
is rifle through the past and and and
decide and you know when they were most
happy with themselves and do everything
possible to get to that weight and keep
to it and I think that that would
necessarily make you healthier
most people healthier than they are now
beyond that I you know I take a vitamin
supplement a general supplement
I think vitamin D I do not take
resveratrol that a lot of people do and
the reason is I'm waiting for a 100%
pure and reliable source of it and then
I will take it and I drink a little wine
and all the data says again there's an
optimum I think the data says that too
much wine is bad but no wine is not
optimum
the right amount of wine is optimum
there's a center in Louisiana called the
Pennington center that has been doing
such studies it's been a long time since
there's been good data on humans on
calorie restriction and part of the
problem has been that humans tend to
cheat on the diet so controlled studies
end up not being so controlled but
recently there have been six months
studies done and what you can do in six
months you can't ask if it's making
people live longer you can't even ask if
it's protecting them against diseases
but you can't ask if it's eliciting the
kinds of physiological changes that you
expect in calorie restriction which
would be a loss of body fat a lowering
of blood glucose so an anti-diabetic
effect a rendering of sensitivity to
insulin the action of insulin these can
all be measured and six months on
calorie restriction in humans that's
roughly the same thing that it does in
mice
now just one footnote on one of those
studies so in rodents what we knew is
that some of these sirtuin activators
could activate muscle to process glucose
better and it was doing that at least in
part by activating the synthesis of
mitochondria these are organelles in
cells they're called the powerhouses of
cells that make energy for cells and by
activating mitochondria you sort of
drive metabolism and you drive the
uptake of glucose from the blood into
the muscle and the processing of glucose
so it's a good thing it's an anti
diabetic thing and this process is can
be driven by thirty-one the survival
gene in muscle in rodents now it was
done first with resveratrol but it turns
out calorie restriction in rodents does
the same thing you activate the
synthesis of mitochondria in muscle okay
and that makes them more metabolically
active and it's a good thing
metabolically
okay now to get back to the humans what
they were able to show
this trial is they took punch biopsies
of muscle from the people that were on
the calorie restriction diet for six
months and what they found in their
muscles was an increase in mitochondria
and an increase in the levels of the
thirty-one protein the protein was
actually increased in the muscle in
response to calorie restriction so that
says that the congruence between mice
and humans may be quite profound with
regard to calorie restriction so we
can't say any there's no direct evidence
in humans about diseases certainly not
about lifespan but at least basic
physiology looks like it might be
similar in humans so that might make a
good prediction about the effects of
calorie restriction but nobody wants to
practice calorie restriction because
it's it's so unpleasant
and so what everybody would like is a
mimetic a drug that would elicit at
least some of the benefits of calorie
restriction